the worrying south african variant of
the covid virus has slipped the net
and has now begun to spread within the
uk
woking in surrey has two of the 11 cases
identified nationwide in recent days
who have no links to south african
travel they were detected by chance
and there could be more it just
highlights how important and how serious
we need to be taking it
we've got to be extra careful that's all
it's a new new variant
which means it's completely different to
the last so you never know public health
england will urgently test
80 000 people in eight areas where the
mutated virus is known to have spread
in london the affected postcodes are in
hanwell tottenham and mitchum
parts of maidstone and boyking are also
being targeted
as are brock's born in hertfordshire an
area of warsaw
and another in southport if you live in
one of these
postcodes where we're sending in
enhanced testing
then it is imperative that you stay at
home
and that you get a test even if you
don't have
symptoms this is so important so that we
can break the chains of the transmission
of this new variant
have a couple of days on them covid
testing kits will be distributed to
homes in the affected areas from tuesday
virus samples from positive cases will
then have their genetic material decoded
to confirm whether the infection is due
to the variant
the variant has already led to a surge
of cases in south africa
precautionary quarantine rules were
brought in just before christmas
for travellers entering the uk 94 have
tested positive
but how the virus escaped to spread
within the uk
is unknown by the time the kent variant
was detected the virus was
already out of control and it swept
rapidly
around the country this time public
health teams believe they spotted the
early sparks of an outbreak
and with early action it gives them a
much better chance of snuffing it out
there is no evidence that the south
african variant causes more serious
disease
but mutations in the virus are causing
concern
a variant that is more infectious and is
less
controlled by the vaccine will continue
to spread
more rapidly even when we've got
vaccine around but what this does mean
is that particularly for people who
haven't who
not able to be vaccinated or have
declined vaccine if you're vulnerable
you are going to be at more risk now
with these new variants circulating than
you would have been with the
the older variants
public health england says all the
vaccines should still prevent serious
illness and death
but moderna is developing a tweaked
version of its jab against the south
african variant as a precaution
in the meantime lockdown will slow the
spread of
all versions of the virus if people
stick to the rules
thomas more sky news invoking